greetings and salutations and welcome
back take gamespot cross kinda funny my
name is Colin Moriarty i'm joined here
by my favorite game developer of all
time keiji inafune a as well as NICU and
we're going to talk about my number 9 as
well as some other pretty cool stuff
we're coming right it about but we're
gonna focus on my number now because i'm
a huge dork with mega man and this is
its spiritual successor so guys thank
you for joining me so much thank you I
appreciate um so we're close we're real
close now to get my tea yes we are how
are you guys feeling about it I don't
know might be no it has lighted I would
schedule another key muscular donna a
machine called a directional scott sauce
now tanoshimi the snap i usually todo
get re-routed pokemon the multi-core
adopt you go Toto it a user any
tanoshinde morocco go menu come and they
sucked on students so we are getting
real close and it's been almost two
years now and you know developing has
been going smoothly and we can you know
almost feel like we can finally deliver
this to the users to the total players
so we're super super excited i am to how
has it been working outside of the
publisher structure I mean obviously are
working with your partners with deep
silver stuff like that but you kick
started the game and kind of developed
it on your own using crowdfunding so how
is that been and how's that been
different it'll Michael Connelly the
project of the crostata motivo de Marte
so publisher to Hoonah todo mi Sunni
pseudo-snake people moon cycle so Nomad
publish atozzio dos uno Donald Shiite
about the artist susan a piano my you
teach me but you re muscle achievement
as your gang guys even together you near
a yoga publisher in a joker and a
publisher at each other also went i
stare ma and publisher I can't you know
toes and Kitty can again I in there by
taking our character to gain you are
referring to the Comerica talked to
Navarro in there so in media no jutsu
juniata correct a name our deepest
sympathy I can get a return de su are no
sera Nissan junior rest my optimus so
simply put lots of lots of more freedom
to the development of the game and we're
not saying that working with the
publisher is a bad thing but it just
sometimes from their standpoint they
want to get the game to be like this
we actually want to do the game like
this so these are split opinions
happening so when that happens that we
we kind of have to take an extra step
you know had a meeting and talk over I
talked about like what to do about this
situation but since we didn't have any
publisher this time we're just you know
doing whatever we want whatever we want
to make and making that again happening
but now we're teaming up with BP silver
and they are really respecting our you
know creative freedom so they're
actually letting us do whatever you want
to do and continuing that so they're
just supporting our development of the
game what's the reaction been to you
know obviously you guys really is kind
of an early beta or so I'm kind of a
sampling of this of the of the game
which I enjoyed very much and it's
basically one stage you kind of learn
the mechanics of the game kind of the
comboing and the point system what's the
reaction been to what you guys have
shown and are you are you optimistic
that people are going to receive it well
Adama honking game with mo betta got on
the scale maquette go so no sign had
soooo called back unintelligible
suitable all mutated the kansas city MO
so mattaponi Batum's latino solo ha no
damage to the Simple Simon struck up
until you handle all keep up in a while
so step aside sure are a todo y negative
in our normal cannot pee akuto conga a
multi-ton scheduled to canary positive
in a hundred hope there today so no
jibun de chegar 80 kya ironic I ishani
an ocelot tomorrow to go to the most ago
posted on awoke after she betta service
to use and is about the more out okatie
no more sugoi ha no viruses name and
when I die in this way started over a
day neon day furthermore it by using
Santa Monica door and I was going on or
I repair on Kauai good I know posted on
hola doctora ana ships so we are you
know before we show the other beta
access to the to the backers we're kind
of worried that there might be some
negative comments about the game how it
turned out because that's the first time
they are actually playing the game and
sing the game in action and until then
it's only about you know concept art or
you know the setting that we're
you know we want to make and we're
showing to them so that was the first
time we were showing the gameplay or
anything like that so we're kind of
worried but from the the beta testing
all the comments are mostly positive and
just couple of weeks back we had this
event called Tokyo indie game fist out
there some of the Japanese players have
first time dude up as a chance to play
the game and they are feedback so i was
also in overwhelmingly positive so
that's kind of big relief for us so not
just the Western audience but also
Japanese organs seems to like what we're
doing right now awesome and how's it
been kind of working with for you with
any creates obviously they did Mega Man
9 at mega man 10 and they have that
old-school pedigree with you know gun
bolt and all these kinds of games but
how has it been kind of working with a
different team a new team to get this
game out or at least work on the game to
get it out I guess later this summer has
it been in eventually we are working
with you know the same team from so from
megaman is so it's the same the same ol
this structure i mean the specific is
like detailed team embrace might be a
little bit there for ok but it's the
same company that's all well yeah I know
I thought maybe different teams that's
awesome the road so that so my
confidence is now through the roof
because my dad were so true so it's been
a good experience that Adama inti Santo
talent like a motor co don't stitch the
Ottomans get amorsolo mommy I look my
cute right Jude scooter looking after
the menisci the more but kum kimo a
senior TT nanticoke on top of the party
know our doctoral students over sauce
and halloween TG taiwan porch in da de
Groot develop a day unwanted even touch
the makanga it's cooked a guru see ya
buddy Anakin to make it was scary to
kiku tokoto Karim there re me ano boku
GA 0 1 tonight expect to security rule
Edo developers and I cannot para a
no-cost ight koo top state auto guinea
anos Rho no koto the epic I take you to
develop on on there and what do I Iggy
matsukura neva by integration archives
of the other you know so great yadi guy
got a muscle so I personally I very very
much trust in d grades when it comes to
making it this kind of game because they
have been making this kind of 2d
side-scrolling all their lives and their
experience they know what to do and
because there's a that trust between us
sometimes when I send them the feedback
they will actually bring back bring back
to me something new or on top of that
feedback because they kind of know that
you know you know I think this is what
you know who Nissan thinking so based on
that if you add this idea into it it we
should make it something better and so
when that happens you know that that's
what we call the good chemistry happens
when that happens I really hope I'm very
glad that I choose indy to create this
game because they really know what
they're doing how are the people that
have seen the game in the fans an old
old school magnetic fans that are
certainly excited but that's how they
reacted to the 3.5 Gees sort of look at
the game as opposed to the more though
my cool guy it's okay cause a mug crash
you can any homeless outside the school
game the fan pet it my knee tango deep
doing on to tomorrow cuz it's almost a
bigger so you know other car the wound
is getting more fun kind of by lenka
swings concerts on feedback autonomous
trucks Sachiko sahaja metodo Guinea
where it also know you- in her note in
wausau shortened schedule she's a gay
masseuse imitate their so out tomorrow
dokuro toga betas obstacle to grow day
sony tengo dignitas 1000 known anterior
que acha negative in her note to Navajo
tanto cuore anak-anak takana 2-0 nahi
hua Qian 8080 I'm re so kooky nice
original not an octazooka each office me
so we're starting off our Kickstarter
campaign there are some people you know
confused or saying almost a negative
thing about 2.5 be and as soon as we
show's starting to show the gameplay or
the beta people are kind of see why we
chose a 2.5
be so the more we show their list they
become you know the comments are become
less and less about they don't like 2.5
be or they don't think this is a good
idea so I think we're going to look good
direction with this and how you know a
couple of the other times that we've met
I often ask you about mega man and now I
want to ask you more about back and
mighty in terms of have you found the
soul of this character I remember you
drawing megaman for me once and it just
came out so naturally it's like you
weren't even thinking about it do you
feel that way now about back and is this
a character that you've really found the
soul in the essence of it don't lie
isn't some sort of later Sheamus getting
more reasons when your son is a local
mama or al-qaeda Martha Corinne the
skidmore super cold Lanka countenance
and look ma no commercial was even
remotely there and she's in the clear
has a high tomorrow under Skidmore
welcome to another chicken cafe could
you can finish it he only sound taking
us on a more for commercial mock their
political a clean up the initial cartier
scenes sauce nano Totenberg position
momentum and I squishy I know a pergola
cocote Madonna coca kanawa su musica
carelessness demo a no Beckett ayudando
dunno skinny not perishable to know
right there the cone i dunno do Tony oh
no yaya kogarah a no sugar no kohaku no
yah dosti Greta katani makita sketch oh
uh no data management guy found a cat or
an attendant Omega motto nazuna garaje I
know Thomas if America k do not stand
there are no hon tony are no Becca G
time or which is you know Thomas you're
scary delayed hookah 13 Inari Mustang
you know this is kind of interesting
case because we are starting a new IP
we're making a new character we're
actually starting from the scratch so as
the development of the game go on we see
more and more about Beck who is back and
what he will do what kind of character
he is so in that sense I'm definitely
seeing more soul in this character in
myself within myself and the funny thing
you should bring up the
and when he draw the megaman sketch for
you because just until a couple weeks
ago we just finished 400 sketches of big
face and the signature so this was
actually one of the other reward we we
posted out during our Kickstarter
campaign so by the time I finished a 400
ones I really feel I can draw him
smoothly hook and almost almost reacting
it is not thinking or thinking about
drawing her anymore that's just kind of
all the flow to it so I think I really
there is a back inside of me now and he
has a solid his own one of the things
that surprised me when I played the beta
and this was a long time ago when you
guys released it was that people you
know this is a spiritual successor to
Mega Man or at least something it's
heavily inspired by mega man but as a
personally as a huge megaman fan in the
classic you know 8-bit megaman fan I see
that this game is not like megaman in
many ways and I'm wondering you know it
seems fast it's it's it's point driven
it's the combo driven a lot of these
kinds of things is it fair to say that
the game is both inspired by mega man
but also quite different at oman
juveniles way uh oh c'mon i found on the
schedule more kick on beta diving my car
appreciate it appreciate the motor home
game oh my look come on slow poke a shot
when you got a mosquito never talked
about she gonna if you know Oh hungry
not done miss me much so so what extent
was I know hey Santa can you are no come
on game day ma mega lo c'mon walk for
each kid scripted cooked a game na na
casa little more for lung cancer but the
pace nominal each case let's quit our
general without fear zone so local non
concave up at all
so now know about 10 game some room
Megaman chiku Naboo part o mundo Godot
by mayor on a copy state-owned motor
scooter baggage and I in there yeah
perigee position or not gonna do so no
mega man I own I hope score action no
can seek amy kinda to Gomez Astaire it's
good tattoo guru garun there nagara in
ontario ghana napolitano Megaman Rio de
Megaman John I TV quien kuwari tasuku
CEO coo neena got a URL in decade or
near at ettore nandan mia mano de kado
Megaman John ie so no Monsieur awesomest
iono scammers orga- on amiga Mon Jan I
enact a puja takuna Megaman Jana shinko
tanto meetha meetha krepta Sony cotton
up today so let's go near a totally non
there are no so Leticia no pets could
attack a puppy no no no so no home [ __ ]
so when we first started making this
game we didn't really have you know the
Mega Man we want to make a make a
million end game or where you know want
to make this game based on Megan or
anything like that we what he had was I
want to make a 2d size for game but I
want to make it new so that's where the
whole idea started and the feedback like
you said it feels kind of megaman but
it's really not that's the kind of thing
I kind of aim for because backing days
all the older of ritual to these high
school games has in a slower gameplay
you kind of want to be safe you keep
your distance with the enemy you want to
die but that kind of gameplay style
where the tent pole I think it's a out
of the date right now so I want
something new and something fast and
speedy so that's where we kind of aim
for and with this game with a new
absorption dash I think we can we
totally achieve that goal so your
feedback saying it looks like a magnet
kind of feels like it but it's not it's
exactly what I ain't would aim for
perfect one of the things that Mega Man
fans seem to relate to most with those
games are the bosses the robot masters
and one of the things I love so much
about the new trailer ways that we got
to see the bosses at least kind of fly
by the screen you know do you anticipate
or you hope that people associate with
some of these bosses like I did as a kid
with magnet man or quick man or bomb man
or whenever when I really loved these
characters you hope that dick that you
kind of capture that same essence with
these particular enemies deauxma my
dad's look my lashes que lo so lo lo
c'mon think Oh busted ah you don't let
you in the bus right here Massimo
soutache I'm appalled 88 a pinnacle both
know mediocrity nominal after the moon
the kokomo muchos a la carrera the van
aterrizamos like a hoe sitting in a bus
stop you know not even this hit amor a
la una zona so no also loco same oh so
dusty Quiana it or consulates crease a
lot on the shoulder so no megami or emo
adobo sunoco set aside even what time
you are at all meghana toget you know
abou sujit i wha how's Vicki I t know
why Nick rasiya tu pathogen and Aikido
punk i know at imagine a man I'd you
know Nick rescue not a scary guy can you
attach their the task etiquette on your
tiara Romano to you the task al-qahtani
up there Cesar Nemo doctor Nagamani na
peppas category scientist could be there
so you belong are on there because it
you know your Italian is an 80 sky
stitch and I you to kroger on there mera
school Yuri are no chaika with Jamie
tentatively skinning up tomorrow to you
gonna get me at MIT number Z is killing
at tomorrow you or not cotati no game
any stats murders so you know compared
with Mega Man the robot masters those
bosses they're actually your enemies but
in Mike number nines case they're
actually not your enemies but there are
your siblings what you're trying to do
is save them from this computer virus
you're kind of cleansing them from this
you know bring back the odd them sell
them to their same self so you're
actually saving them you're not just
killing them or defeating them and like
you said we wanted to make each of the
bosses you know
give them a unique personality unique
ability and they cancel stand alone by
themselves and I think we have really
achieved that with this game so we're
hoping how hope working for vinyl is by
the end of the game you know every one
of the players will actually love each
of the the bosses that you've fought
because you actually depends on which
boss is safe they actually come into the
stage and help you out time to time so
that's the kind of relationship we want
to try to aim with a you know getting
the players and the bosses I'm curious
you know I know that when you created
megaman rockman in the 80s you drew and
created at least the first six enemies
and obviously Mega Man himself and then
you open it up to you know basically
kids and adults in Japan to create the
rest of them in the new which are all
them in your style did you create all
these enemies yourself or did you let
some of the guys it any creates do their
thing it'll ma look once good lucky this
I tional title in tokyo on the same but
even that's your height alone so not
only called kickoff ankara design poster
started by a telecom on this in it yeah
80 conch I know follow my key number 9
by my what she returned item on this
scale amorsolo contains mg banana
sandwich even the kite on the show pass
a little more fun designer it on the
show are no concept on a character
design is reena ganga our nanny cam
there a todos que no joke sister she was
using a car good theory hua shi shi shi
negara I know how many cold I
authenticator so no more money not
parasitic yu garden back at all I know
it's early season agarrate good till
cata today I'm money I know you know
honey no cosa got this Regina yoni kung
kaya kung right there a ton de kado ya
kun original design Agha I mean honest
and ashy design issue tu foto de I'll
continue I was Secretary toca stay nah
gah bah he can't get it I know Iran
nuh-uh no itarsi kotaku Torre Donati
taken up to Moya's so i guess the simple
answer is like half and half because i
didn't actually design them but i gave
them a lot of feedbacks from my
perspective and within concept we have a
couple designers really good designers
they are the guys who actually mainly
designed oval design for the robots so
one day you know bringing me that those
their design I'll give them feedback and
sometimes I'll I should i do a do a
quick doodle and saying you know
explaining what kind of things I have in
mind but that ended up being just that
and then the next time they bring by the
design will be exactly the same thing I
drew so it's kind of weird thing that we
did with the deadlines because I
actually don't want to have too much on
my own so design influence into the
designs but the designers actually
wanted my influence into the designs so
it's kind of weird mixture that's
happening right now so I that's why I
say you know it's kind of happened huh
and I'm curious you know earlier I asked
about the publisher structure and
kickstart in your game and crowdfunding
and all that what's the feedback loop in
in terms of getting feedback obviously
from the people that are backing you
obviously you're reading the comments
and you're reading there the information
they're saying on the beta and stuff how
have you reacted to that because it must
be a different experience than being a
publisher where you're maybe they're
playtesting there may be paying to have
the game examined by external
playtesters but you're not having direct
feedback so how is that experience been
making this head so full time on its
amor solo food and oreos a publisher
Santoya territory ido feedback with the
main publish on feedback i texted Emma
baka baka deco reality tobacco alcohol
kuta moments can Punk I know add much
Chris atom project update such paramo a
token solo bar cart / cough Ankara
shield water cooling the Skidmore so
impatient not so slow a melodic about
universal or don't you can't say stuff
like about seattle to the commercial
haha
Hunico are picky cannot go among the
snare / user now ghana ghana game there
at all hot soup i know you tara nanka
gets combined hug chosen by easily the
apush messed up you did so no what about
my knocked on my chin han gauri had to
buy saratoga artist supermodel scooped
it to you they alter the dexter monetize
their use on video ipod lagoon guy kicks
tata they are tan de Arte de maximum
nanyem addicting i thought i did use on
feedback we did he could you all nighter
Ibaka na hoona Stein diode till dark
ricky matee ramanagara i know he can't
Oh DDT toga want Oneko use a maritime
law regional not the sort of our know
Kiko Sutton Hoo / Getty ya later Russia
an omen doc cycle modern de que todo
Chiquito juventa semi-auto Guinea news
on cooked you see any steering there and
also najera i don't use any I know
Miccosukee night you are [ __ ] mother
dick teen i'm on all those that I idiot
I'm not gonna get you an item on there
if I'm iota talking no chica I botanica
totally kita ceramic with Akhenaten so
generally speaking i'm sure this is not
a hundred percent a case but when you're
working with a publisher when you're
saying announcing some game in this
year's e3 that means you have already
worked on the game for at least a year
maybe half years before that so whatever
you're showing and the first time you're
getting the feedback from the users or
the players is based on what you're
showing to them at that point but in the
Kickstarter case we actually don't even
have anything to show to the backers
whatever we have at that point we just
show it show it to everyone I think in a
sense that's almost like a natural way
to do it because we are building this
game together with the fence so they
have the right to know what's going on
and what's happening to be within the
project so whenever we actually asked
the backers to do a survey or a design
contest or whatever that's happening
that's actually when we are you know
within the dev team that's there's
openings until we split into two ways or
three ways then we're all turn into the
backyard saying you know what we can't
decide what's going on what to do with
this one what do you guys think I think
that relationship
between backers and us the dev team went
really nicely in this case so that
that's the kind of main difference
between the the publisher doing the
publish away while doing a Kickstarter
way has it been interesting have you
noticed the influence that you've had
and this project has had on other
Kickstarter's I feel like there was a
direct influence with Coach igarashi
specifically with a blood stain which
you know has done extraordinarily well
on Kickstarter have you seen that is
that kind of honor you to kind of
convince other developers your peers
basically that they also can go
independent they also can go to the
director to their fans to get exactly
what they want so Ken engines to repeat
the first part I can hear because on the
oh I'm sorry basically the question was
with something like Coach igarashi she's
blood stain does mr. and if we may
realize we think that he's inspired
other developers you know especially his
peers in japan right if they can find
great success to by delivering exactly
what may be primarily Western audiences
one but otherwise wouldn't get from the
publisher structure it or not psyching
you taught your son but at the same do
it goki no I don't say cause I'm not
sure get them or my name isn't akin you
are so no not even know my key number 90
Seco de corps who can also independent
also know a bit of Baga not on you made
a developer Kirko good start and finish
on between e mo a mysterious source net
oh no you cute i'll go to a dick rockin
out to you yeah buddy and kick start our
go Tonio the challenges stay on a jeep
when they meet you here I could to you
go to oh man you got a son more mono
Syracuse a more like in your honor so
the Domo Godot I know so you nagaoka at
iroko to a texture cannot go grab our
motto my octoroon de estar to generate a
mob or not automatic steering day
gorsuch Antonio tesara nucleotide I
didn't generate not even an optimist so
you know I can't really say this for a
hundred percent for sure but hopefully
my Kickstarter had some kind of impact
to them when they were thinking about
and maybe we should do one kick starter
because we actually started this and we
prove that it's possible to start a to
start a IP or to start a project through
Kickstarter and I think that's one other
thing I think we should have encouraged
them and by now since our game is almost
over we almost saw at the finish line
once we finish the game we can encourage
more people saying you know what we can
actually finish a project through a
Kickstarter so hopefully that's the case
and I wish you know yu suzuki son the be
hopefully a big success in their kicker
i know they're already founded yeah oh
yeah they're doing great one last
question before we go to break for the
other side of the interview how should
people primarily be playing mighty and i
asked this question because the game is
point-based it's fast are you
anticipating that people going to play
it in a more elegant style are they
gonna play it more fast i think maybe
speedrunning it are they going to be
going for high scores or is it basically
are you hoping that people play it at
their leisure and i asked that simply
because with 8-bit Mega Man games for
instance you either play them you know
you play them well or you play them so
or plotting or your speeder on them and
that's basically it but now there's all
these kinds of things to measure your
progress and how you're playing it so
how do you anticipate people will play
it or how do you want to see them keep
up people play it's like starting of us
no I'm not calling him with the kick
Omaha at the peso I game this game oh
you got some games when you could have
it all see what the gameplay not a
disaster caicos I should go to solitude
oh you don't lock associate at least a
solo Nana sonoma a dishonor come on Nina
creation while I started in Adam
lallana's so speedo and America so no
8020 you can take away any resources
solano congas lucu can get a tow Tyrone
Tasha toyota motor may pera home Tony
later on a game otonashi matata
motorista Madiba ana teresa cottagey no
actual game tonight ultimately the
reservoir at raja kata kata no seminary
to motor and a vespa donor some kusadasi
02 scene II don't know Sunday good ta
re-type mud tech demo esto te Tai Tonga
Tonga Mochaccino Erica Tata more arte de
su naughty a mega mondo nacion at Attica
at alstom Okanagan Jesus assuming its
clarity its reputation icky icky
neogenic they don't know how thick the
yukata today
sunday KO nimo take ya gotta tear I know
yet i oniy given the playa de kiriona
attitude Scott's marine on there see so
you took karate okay Iman odm to Thomas
in there Hickory taranta Massimo cannot
attempt our sticker tre gotta mow us on
the marae teramo sir Angelica so I think
actually we can go me on both ways when
you play this game you can either you
know just shooting the enemies and
killing them and then progress or you
can actually stunned them and use your
absorption dash and finished off them
fast and you know speedrun kind of thing
so the the thing I really wanted to do
is giving the players the option of
choosing the style they want to play you
can play with it you know like the the
old 2d side-scroller game style or you
can play the new style with you know
speed and good tempo so my island itself
you know he made himself wants to play
with the fast tempo and speedy you know
gameplay but I'm pretty damn pretty sure
that there are people out there who
wants to play meet the old style so they
have the choice to however they won't
play it but I like the speedy one for
myself perfect so we're about to go to
commercial but before we do I want you
know my number 9 comes out when what
platforms will be on so people know
Michael mostly commercial non-skid Oh
Mikey nominal okay righto home at all
haha baby ah SE passe Susan imagine a
man I raw 80 xbox one playstation 3 for
xbox on Doc Martin it were you Oh God
cougars--no geology need them be there
to buy this is a guy they were any home
Baku matter who I told you hot tuna tuna
up to buy this so the shortest version
is we have every single console out
there and so the name to 950 alternative
everything we are PC for steam and mac
and linux and ps4 ps3 and three xbox 360
X plus 1 and we you were coming out at
September 15th pearl in north america
and September 18 for along the
roll and three TDs and PS Vita version
are coming out a little bit later than
that perfect well there it is by your
number nine we're going to come back
with 30 more minutes with my favorite
developer of all time keiji inafune a
we're gonna talk about some other things
so I want to talk a little bit about the
Japanese gaming industry his other game
recore and of course other random things
like when his favorite game of this show
is it's already a drink so we'll be back
right after this
what's up we're back with keiji inafune
a as well as NICU we're talking about
mighty number nine as well as some other
cool stuff but what I want to ask mr.
and food a now since he's such a
seasoned veteran of the games industry
is something really simple we're here at
e3 we're seeing lots of new games do mr.
androoni get see any the press
conferences and what did he think of
those i'm not home by easy day funny 90
cal cold tea not the game of the bath
but also sold them up a game not a
message bosnia no smokin guy in history
or most arizona game going out to move
today I know more that's why my docomo
mutual re mask at all and here tied up
till game toca oh no madam aesthetic a
McGraw yeah to utter baby ki Mallika
Caterham tanah rata ritika stay oh no
hon tony oh no no no don't i got the
yoruba no he not the title snap it
muscle naka de Monaco out to you now to
know dr. decade oh I nanometer school oh
no brand new no original title to know a
product on their core my padrino met
imaginas connect so actually you know
I've seen a lot of interesting games you
know some some of the games i actually
want to play and looking forward to some
of the other games actually announced
their release date that's getting me
really excited but my personal favorite
is this game called recore which is
original IP by me and I mature studio
and Microsoft that's all I'm really
looking forward to that one hearing more
news about that game yeah tell me a
little bit more about about rapport and
I mean I know you can't get too into it
I me not you have you know publishers
here how did this even happen armature
obviously a studio of Metroid Prime
veterans from retro how did you guys
meet up with them and then how did you
find your way on the xbox it'll not only
one seed age don't you sign this game
Oklahoma City go got a [ __ ] Mastan this
car though you can k the armature
talking about they do you can get a
micro sufficient living advances so
shahama chopped or 80 jitt 10 cup
Considine issue is equal to sit there
are no tsukitachi de carrera to see go
to Kadesh tetanus una de cacao movie
marathon day oh no projected I was man
acuna Japan's kiddo
naruto naruto mocha re tied to Coto de
credito nanika gangadharan I gotta go to
Soviet eat at oconee a game odometer
cordillera teen up the you know their
nests or 080 publish an emoticon dead
tickets there at Microsoft Oh Nemo's
Condit aki-nee Microsoft Omo so we
harness me security the jensen episode
20 today Microsoft of chima height the
URI a no naka be automatic tenaga
pumpkin so our studio I actually have
worked it with them backing the Capcom
days and the relationship with that
studio was really nice and the game was
turning out very nicely but you know
since I left the Capcom of the company
that I think that project got cancelled
and didn't move up move forward from
there so you know it's a bummer but I
always thought really liked amateur
studio and always thought about you know
working with him again so when you know
this whole thing came out I was thinking
you know maybe I want to do something
new and then that's when I thought about
amateur studio and I started talking
with them and see their it's interested
in working some kind of new project and
they just said yes so now we're looking
for a new publisher or someone to work
without to work together with this title
and that's when Microsoft came into the
picture and they are not only being a
publisher but they're actually bringing
their own team into the dev team and
it's pretty much like three companies
working together on this title you know
speaking of that and kind of finding the
team's you want to work with people
certainly must be knocking down your
door right to work with you or have you
are you approached all the time my
publishers and developers the kind of
produce their game direct their game
creatively direct their game whatever
you must be approached casa it's my
units honestly muscle or you don't have
hot enough fish in your opinion on
chiquita do in this heat amor que cold
tub you know who else on the whole
anymore each scenario tied to her evil
coulda done on this Gator more so what a
hint at all on this car soho the snare
so many canals anatomia day tomo
terrorist attacks a neutral moon disk
adore now gonna go home Toni ko new
business to Karachi day 80 single Ganga
zucchini i rana show a garter toss
there are no Antonio no name makuu you
don't have all day auditory not on
Mondays quedo no capricho original toca
su mano at all moto moto metal Rosita in
otago bazinga but ok to know cannot even
your mama's so not as much as you think
people do tend to come to me about you
know I'm making new ideas or making new
games but you know from a business
standpoint it's kind of it's kind of
getting very hard to start a new IP or
start a new franchise so there's you
know less people coming to me saying you
know let's work something together
there's just too many hurdles or too
many walls to crash before you can get
your green LED or started so hopefully
you know the game industry will become
more open to new ideas working like new
IPs that's I think when all people you
know will feel more freely approaching
to me or approaching to each other
starting a new IPs and you know what
struck me about recours opposed to MIT
is that might ease on everything like
you guys were saying you're laughing
about my knees on on every platform
imaginable and you know records gonna be
on xbox one specifically that certainly
must make it easier right when you're
overlooking a project or helping to
produce a product to focus on one
particular platform as opposed to many
implants you have the resources of a
publisher and a big stakeholder actually
a platform holder so is that just a
totally different experience than what
you're used to so 19 I'm gonna grab it a
lot of mighty mo temple at home during
this keyomo so mad aquatic constant on
each plateau home tonight it's got a
kilometer item watch out of its flat
homie yeah yeah see the moon let's get
the loan then I got bit in the hood G
right about 30 Sullinger sozinho to a
hospital at home day at Ordonez toga oh
no era bassani oh no a pre submitted a
story together ooh katachi ito motor une
des cadeaux an oh yeah but some way can
I boo boo muah DOTA muy mas de Maria no
mistaking ito kairana me Tara Goonan
washed avocado naked or the memory
taxonomy sota gentleness in de muro de
you know every game create a toast Ava
juventus in reality cotton and a animoto
met Eva
more immersive she told akira kurosawa
Nakata's they are eaten up to kimmo to
Artemis so it's kind of two sides
fighting against each other within
myself because one side you know as a
game creator I want my game to be played
by everyone right that means all
platforms however you know that's kind
of brings in the the hurdles of you know
porting into different consoles and just
done much you know extra work to have to
be done but on the other hand doing only
one consoles we can actually really
focus on that thing and you'll take me
technical wise it's much easier to do
just one consoles so there's just always
the two sides fighting and fighting
against each other and also there is a
little business aspect or the schedule
or anything like that so in a sense
there's one easier way but that's not
the really way that we should be taking
you know as a good game creator myself I
want everyone to be able to put power to
play my game and tell me little bit more
about what's going on at calm steps
because you guys seem to have a lot of
balls in the air at every at any given
time I mean I remember you know soul
sacrifice for instance in all these
other games how many games you have in
development right now aurelie said
they're like you tendrils on in terms of
the grant you might be producing how
many of those games are development as
though my concept of the clash a lot of
people you don't know projectile it
should be [ __ ] highly congested in
this case I what other but my my hustle
got some sort of sacrifice kept you
gotta pass a mosquito more McCain's
almighty more liquidy mosquito more but
died during this hero don't grind again
our domain projector those aneema
hostilities or denature i'm a year
behind a sauce on a no position no co
sao tu toh woh yamato after you don't
know Tommy Oh no ha Nick Macario yeah
goa capture area or tatra son naked a
non coca hasta una rata on Tony roenicke
anohana sorry talaga ruto an asana
Kagura ironic acordaste asuna sameera
reddy regimented no detail wha gwan past
decade account gets to develop as an IT
you go to vivienda tomatillo tomatillo
una caja de terre toka integration
akashi-kun de ano hito GA
you know conceptus I arriba y una casa
tu carro as an Agora what's your game
Kaoru Kato a row those in his manager go
to a ticket to you soon or ETA Cass
there are no Paxton on a la pregunta GZA
utara are no mother the 22 tarwackis and
I in there the Jirga ilocano cottage is
a calculator naka de arroz Jamuna can
guide a modem but are staying there so
you see me kappa so I game no scrubs
critic at all Stamos so company wise we
just have too many too many ideas right
now that's happening and this is for my
personal point of view I actually have a
stack of pitch document on my desk just
sitting there ready to go and we
actually have a boat always just ideas
that's in there or they pitch document
in there you know we can just put bring
out and talk with people and see if
they're interested we're at the kind of
company that's making ideas or making
concept so that's what we're doing right
now so that's why we have so many ideas
in in the air that's at this moment and
personally as a game creator you know my
career is not you know limitless there's
only so many numbers of games i can do
in like gaming career and within that
time i hope that i can do as many I can
you know make realize as many ideas as
possible inside my head and that's what
we're aiming for right now one of the
things I've always admired about you
even though megaman is like my favorite
thing of all time is that you've
produced or had your hands on a lot of
other different games whether you're at
capcom are now and you it's an emu show
or dead rising or whatever it might be
you like to make different kinds of
games soul sacrifice there's one kind of
game might ease another kind of game are
there any kind of games that you haven't
been able to make that you want to make
a role-playing game or so you know or
like a JRPG something super nerdy like
that or is it or you kind of comfortable
in these certain spaces at all my United
something you don't know John in the
game or your dick Toki Huna Conte Mosca
don't tell them I sort of thought
sacrificing the only game lot about the
rising again what he must see they were
you don't know Johnny addicted only skim
also nothing I you wanna motto tonight
John in the game deck for ecology I
think I not in an alley Moscow so the
snare inoyori techo Cecilia
prepare zombie tia tanaka dr. Tanaka on
Omaha sky are eaten at rudino's Bukater
died I a tectonic adore my appt tonight
gordito so the snare oh no a pari na
jana gana anno con que mas cosas más
hacer como si ni tomo tereko we are a
Samaritan de kado a break chiisana
kodomo Cara Oh tonometer zynga omoshiroi
tomoyo game zoo crickey up to meet na
Nagara ish annoyed a decayed against or
Adeste cosine up you know birthday oh no
Meah ma sanga be a massacre Sangha oh no
can't Anna connoisseur ichiban music
osito koro chato anomia missoni
Kazakhstan out Timmy idea yeah I like
the who knew about them as me so all my
games until this point I knew I haven't
done a lot of different journals a lot
of different themed games but most of
them are you know focused on one group
of audiences so for example you know
Zambia dead rising is totally for zombie
fans and you know my number nines for
the the 2d size for hardcore also
Japanese game lovers and if I have to
pick one genre it's not really a jungler
but if I have to pick something that I
really want to do is something that that
will appeal to kids you know students
and adults or even the seniors at the
same time some a game that will be loved
by all absolutely everyone something
that Shigeru Miyamoto song it's doing so
easily and doing so many times hopefully
I cannot reach to that level and make a
game similar to that and hopefully I'm
thinking if I know is weak or can you
know make that dream come true can you
tell me anything about recore in terms
of what it even is that is it a shooters
at the third person shooter I could you
say anything about the game at all to
give us a little bit inside what is
Bitcoin its eat a MOOC enjoy hunting and
amino day you recall too very much of
nanomaterials scenario Noriko ok no
challenger still booboo not a burrito so
no shoot atoka soy utana Roboto Roboto
Scott a tecate tu anari tu foto de
oaxaca
suriname tarragona konishi Coco Moreta
so no kimochi tika Robo Toto Toto kikuno
ninja mimi tina boone dietary toka
sunoco re tone okonjo dietary toca su
you boo boo consciousness ariana game is
tied to cut about there so what are they
okay no challengers at a ceramic we
cater to you CAC Co moti nagar a parent
there are no sonnet are you to mock
semitic really cannot do ministry so the
record we're not just trying to make a
third-person shooter or a robot
customization game or anything like that
but the general idea or the message we
want to you know show presented with
this title is sort of the human drama
between robots and humans with this this
thing called core with this idea i think
we should we should be able to present
this broad idea of when a human drama
between the robots and humans so it's
kind of hard to say at this point
without showing you anything without
showing any example but we have a real
big dream to realize with this game the
turnaround if the Torah seems pretty
quick as the game been in development
for a while it'll kick gonna conquer and
Tory are there a la sua decal they're
hung out in this heat amandote don't I
both hi honey makhani the initial part
so no mama de julianka gets a Machado
ishani yeah text and a at ok cool oh no
more proto move up there oh no you talk
sorry Joe tight ilka muhando ruh ruh
scared no katachi sukhino danke in
height there in there dystonia mota mota
miss le ruban des cadeaux my rawness
ENIAC taking over modern day and mother
isla de Roco comedy septimus enghadr are
no Connery dichiara to extremes so it's
been 14 months since we first starting
work
armature studios and we actually have a
prototype you know already done and the
network into the next stage I think we
have a very solid gameplay we should be
able to show but you know business
strategy wise we think you know for this
III will only show you the trailer and
then we'll keep the get actual gameplay
or the demo to another another
opportunity but in reality we actually
have something in a really solid already
built for the record what does it look
like when you know you're obviously in
Japan and they're in the United States
what does it look like when you're
producing or helping to create a game
like this you have to come over a lot or
is there just a lot of emails exchanged
and a lot of files and ft peeing and all
that kind of stuff what does that kind
of situation look like to kind of keep
you sane since you obviously have so
many games of development and you're
obviously thousands of thousands of
miles from the people that are actually
making the game heads a guy shot my
chest I don't know how many find out in
skinny more this I concept United
somewhat a man you home it is so no
cannot cure recon they were co-opted
doughnut on gentleman up in Ibiza hello
yogurt alex arias are it or email it ago
them smashed even oh god don't let
continue not a shocker oh no don't oh
boo kishori I asked you not the Iman or
skype take on tonight's nakuru go to
bday Kieran day a no Q nakato got famous
on skype date Snagit a URI Russia on my
issue at oceanic kite organic I to car
so i could amo take him as she do they
are no hasty hasty are good hi sista
modern-day Jimmy noho Cara oh no I much
estrogen et tu lagaa a new staff ooga
Arnold Texas ani Austin it on de austin
de she go to salute to koto mo yata
masuda technique in historical occasion
agarra sky-boat Scotty I know soon any
communication Torrio vegetables will
pretty much use all the methods you
mentioned right there emails Skype
meeting actually sometimes I actually
fly over to amateur studio and talk to
them face-to-face but in a sense
compared to when we worked with them
back in calc young days it's much easier
now to work with the oversea developer
because you know the technology is there
for us to use
email skypes all that kind of stuff we
can you know use within the development
process so it's easier and it that's
definitely making things move faster
perfect Nick so I couldn't hear you and
kevin was talking to my earpiece so much
that i thought i was gonna actually
strangle a man so are we going to break
down when coming back or are we picking
2 i'll be picking whatever you whatever
you need ok so so that's it so we'll
wrap it up here with with an opponent
son ok mr. Inafune a i tell you this
every time i meet you you are my
favorite game developer you will always
be my favorite game developer Mega Man's
the reason that I got into this industry
and I started playing video games as
always I want to thank you for your time
I wish you the very best of luck in your
future endeavors my very best at all the
teams are working with I cannot wait to
play mighty number 9 so thank you so
much for your time sound oh my god you
did it alone this kiddo I don't owe you
nothing sunday funday it's even more
district to say to the game greater
velocity this ain't even called yoga
knee height external oh come on nope ok
Donna Leonte nemo unus on your combat
agito in my teen continuity to ensure
she columns 30 over Sheamus how they
aren't a nice egg money and come back to
assign keywords arigato thank you so
much oh you're very welcome